deadly Duo is a buddy cop Horror Story
we begin with a dilemma that the Joker
finds himself in you definitely get the
idea that something's going on here it
has something to do with the joker and
then we move to Batman doing his Batman
stuff he's investigating a crime he
realizes The Joker has done something
that gives Batman kind of no out and by
the end of the first issue they're
teammates you know hence the title uh
deadly Duo Jim Lee and I have been
friends for years and every once in a
while he would say hey come on do a
Batman when I finally got around to like
pitching it and then getting actually
working on it it's been about seven
years but this is a story that I want to
tell and a story that I want to draw
the best part for me about this being a
black label book is the fact that it's
not in continuity which is you know for
me as a Storyteller is is very free it
is dark it is kind of creepy but there
is some funny stuff in there the way
that I approached the world of Batman in
my style was kind of being true to who I
am as a Creator my Batman looks fast you
know he's powerful because I've always
considered Batman to be like a real
force of nature for me the joke has
always been a physical threat not
because of this physical strength per se
but of of his innate insanity and I hope
that you know the fans of Batman and
Comics have as much fun reading it as I
did writing and drawing it but it's fun
foreign